once trench warfare ossified conflict on
the Western Front and World War one
there was a desperate need to break up
that slog that quagmire part of the
solution was in airpower
but the British had discovered it came
right that if they made a vehicle with
an internal combustion engine and they
armored the size and put a machine gun
or a small cannon on it then in theory
you couldn't stop it it would run over
men and their bullets would bounce off
and out of that experience of somewhat
limited success but nevertheless success
of getting through German trenches there
became a race to make armored vehicles
and by in fact the end of World War one
there were several thousand tanks in the
American and French and British army
although the Germans really didn't build
any at all during the period between
World War one and World War two the idea
of tanks is sort of the mother of all
bought the mother of all weapons on the
battlefield took hold it was analogous
to profits of air power profits of
strategic bombing just as people like
Billy Mitchell and Duet and Italy had
said the bomber will change warfare
there were people in Britain Liddell
Hart general fuller people in Germany
hands Guderian who said no what will
change warfare is an armored vehicle
that's reliable on the ground and it
will plunge through enemy lines and
adjudicate all ground fighting it was
kind of analogous to the idea of the
premise of the battleship unleash a
battleship once it destroys its
counterparts it gets in like a wolf
among sheep in a convoy and there's
nothing around that can stop it it'll
just blow apart ships that are
transporting needed material and the
same thing would be true on the
battlefield once you have a tank force
it bursts through the enemy's formations
how can you stop it and it will just go
on ad infinitum and take territory and
win the war outright this was very
influential when World War two started
nobody quite knew what a tank should be
so if you looked at tanks and the
relative militaries they were quite
different should a tank have one cannon
or two should it be like the char B tank
in France or the American Lee and grant
that had two cannon should it have a 30
caliber machine gun or a 50 caliber
machine gun or maybe three machine guns
in addition to the cannon should it have
narrow tracks and sort of go faster or
wide tracks and it would be more stable
should it have sloped armor that would
make it a little bit more uncomfortable
inside the tank but provide greater
protection are straight sides how big
should the turret be should it have two
men three men that can help load should
it have a radio should it have a diesel
engine which would provide more
reliability and diesel fuel although
that you get fewer gallons per barrel
boil is a little bit cheaper as a first
stage of refinement and it has better
mileage than a gasoline engine and it's
not as likely to ignite when the tank is
hit or should have gasoline that is you
get more you know gallons of gas per
barrel of oil but more importantly a gas
is easier to start in the winter and
winter operations so whether there's
this great conundrum that nobody quite
knew what a tank should look like even
what it should be how big should the gun
be 37 millimeters 50 millimeters 75
millimeters those challenges were by
1945 as we saw with airplanes and ground
soldiers they reached another consensus
so as the war got into sophisticated
armored operations especially on the
eastern and western fronts by 1944 there
was an I guess we can use the term air
tank there was a standard vision that
all sides shared about what it would be
the most successful tame it should be
somewhere between 25 and 30 tons
anything bigger than 30 it was hard to
transport it was hard to cross bridges
with it anything less and it was too
vulnerable it could be it could be
easily destroyed
chillier air power or their tanks it
should have tracks that are wider so it
could prevent slipping it should have a
low profile it shouldn't be like a
Sherman tank that suck up too high and
made an easy target it it should have a
gun that was at least 75 millimeters in
preferably 76 or even 88 or 90
millimeters and although the Germans
never really built a diesel fuel tank
the Americans only did a few Sherman
models that were diesel fueled and the
British didn't use diesel at all the
Russians with their t-34 tank had
discovered that diesel was the ideal
fuel because of problems of igniting
that gas offered and so and their diesel
aluminum engines were very very
efficient they were reliable so at the
end of the war the idea was you want a
30-ton tank with 76 millimeters and
above it should be diesel-powered etc
but it took thousands of tank crews to
be killed and wounded to find out what
was the preferable tank